francia inició la intervención militar
en mali en enero de 2013 a petición del
entonces presidente john conde traure
cuando una ofensiva yihadista amenazaba
la capital del país bamako se solicite
solicite y obtuve el apoyo aéreo de
francia en el marco de la legalidad
internacional
mal y su pueblo no están solos en esta
lucha contra el terrorismo con decenas
de ataques aéreos el ejército francés se
embarcó entonces en la operación serbal
en mali en cuestión de semanas las
principales ciudades del norte del país
quedaron liberadas sin embargo la
operación duró año y medio hasta agosto
de 2014 cuando el operativo militar
francés se transformó porque la amenaza
terrorista persistía entraron en la
cooperación militar países del sahel
como mauritania níger y chad y la misión
de naciones unidas minustah la
intervención pasó a llamarse operación
marcan en total 5 mil 100 soldados
franceses y 8000 malienses han combatido
en el operativo con la presencia de
15.000 miembros de naciones unidas con
el objetivo oficial de privar a los
militantes islamistas de acceder a
medios de combate de comunicación y de
aprovisionamiento en el trópico
es utópico pensar que llegaremos a parar
todos los flujos para al menos impedir
este paso y mostrar que estamos perdidos
en la frontera ya son buenos
desde el inicio de la intervención 51
soldados franceses han perdido la vida
en mali mientras que la cifra de
malienses muertos a manos del ejército
de francia no es clara según naciones
unidas un bombardeo de la aviación
francesa mató al menos a 19 civiles que
celebraban una boda a principios de este
2021 ocho años después de intervenir
francia suspenderá la misión según
anunció este jueves el presidente
francés emmanuel